Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters and we are going to be talking about the question
I'm doing chemotherapy or not.
When you get a diagnosis of cancer, it can be scary and it's easy to get pressured into
something that maybe you're not ready to do.
So if you're certainly ready to do it, have peace about chemotherapy by all means that you
just need to do what you think is best for your body.
But that's not what this little talk is for.
That is for the people that were offered chemotherapy.
Maybe sometimes even feel pretty pressured into chemotherapy and they're trying to decide
what to do.
So let's walk through some steps, I have some rules here.
So rule number one is to slow down a little bit.
I know many times it is imperative that you make a decision quickly on the treatment plan
that you're going to do with your cancer.
If you have a very aggressive cancer, like a pancreatic cancer, you don't have a lot of
time to decide on whether you're going to do chemotherapy or not, but still you always
have more time than they recommend.
So rule number one is just please, if you're thinking about doing chemotherapy, radiation
or surgery, usually you have a lot more time that they say you do, slow down a little
bit and think about it.
I give the example of one of my patients who was told that if she doesn't do radiation
immediately, that she has just a couple days to live while she was in the hospital with
vertebral compression fracture because of cancer had spread to her bones.
And she was adamant against doing the radiation of the radiologist, oncologist, caveman, and
said, if you don't do it, you have a couple days to live.
You call me on the phone and I kind of talked her into maybe it would be in her best interest
to do the radiation because that's what I believe for this case.
She had a lot of pain in her back because of the compression fracture.
And we've just seen good results radiating the spine in a specific spot.
So she agreed to the radiation after they told her if she didn't do the radiation, she had
just a couple days to live.
And then the radiation oncologist said, great, I'll get my nurse in here.
The nurse came in and said, okay, we could get you started in three weeks.
She was absolutely living.
You told me I had three days to live, if I don't do the radiation, I agree to it.
And you can't get me in to get scheduled to do it for three weeks.
How does that work?
Who's telling this truth here?
Well, she did end up passing away, but she lived six and a half years.
This is a long time ago after that, you know, metastas to the spine and she had metastas
several places.
And she did that radiation session, the several sessions of the radiation and then just continued
on a natural approach and she didn't really quite well.
So rule number one, just slow down a little bit.
And then rule number two, don't follow another's dogma.
I've said over and over again in many videos, in my book, you don't want to be dogmatic
about your health care, meaning that you don't want to be just stuck.
I'm only going to do an alternative approach and you're not going to have at least have
your open up your eyes to maybe chemo, maybe radiation, maybe surgery is in your best interest
as well.
But most people are on the other side of that coin where they don't do any alternative
care and they don't even think about it because goodness, wouldn't their oncologist recommend
that because he's only in it for my best.
Well, I'm sure most oncologists only want the best for their patients, but the truth is
they have three tools in their tool bank just because everybody else did it.
Grandma and your sister and your aunt did chemotherapy does not mean it's right for you.
So slow down a little bit back to rule one and don't do something just because everyone
else is doing it.
Don't need to follow another person's dogma, slow down a little bit.
Rule number three, you have to be your own doctor, especially in today's health care conundrum
that's out there, you have got to take control of your life and be your own doctor.
You have to do your own research, do not just blindly surrender control to your surgeon,
your oncologist, your car partner, your antropath, whoever it is, you have to be your own doctor.
You have to take charge of your body and you want your doctor to be your coach, your doctor
to be your leader, your doctor to be part of your team.
You're going to have multiple doctors be part of your team, but you have to ultimately
be the maybe switch metaphors, the general contractor of your of your construction of your body
here.
So make sure you take charge and be your own doctor.
Number four, there's a wisdom in a multitude of counselors.
So you want to get second opinions, you want to get opinions from other people.
Now be careful.
There's a balance here, you don't want every person that is in your church coming up and
telling you what to do, but there is a wisdom in a multitude of counselors, good, solid people
that have interest in you and there, everybody's going to have their bias.
I have my bias towards more of an alternative approach.
Take that into consideration and then surgeons are going to have a bias.
What do surgeons do?
They do surgery, chemotherapy doctor is going to have a bias towards chemotherapy.
We'll take it all in balance and don't necessarily listen just to one person.
That's what wisdom is.
You gain knowledge from multiple sources and then you go to God for what is your answer in
this situation.
Have godly people help you walk through this.
That's the key.
Rule number five, that's what I mean, helping godly people walk through this is you need
to reason together.
God said, come, let us reason together.
He created your brain for a reason to use it and to not just again surrender it like mush
to somebody else because you're in an emotional disaster right now or slow down, get out of your
emotional disaster, get some good biblical counsel, some good healthcare counsel, and let's
talk about it with either myself or if that's what you're a patient of ours, that's schedule
a time to talk to me or Michelle or whoever you need to talk to or your pastor who could
reason, could put this stuff together.
So many times you feel like you're drinking out of a fire hose when you go to the standard
medical doctor or a college is because they just hammer you with a lot of pressure and
fear that to do something, and if you don't do it, you're a bad person or stupid person
or everybody else is doing it, that's not the reason to do anything.
You have to have peace about what you're doing and you have to know that God is leading you
to do it and you're using wisdom and a sound mind in your decision making process.
So I'll help you reason together and we'll walk through it.
I'm not against chemotherapy, I'm just against using it foolishly and against using anything
foolishly, even you know alternative care foolishly.
You just have to walk through it, sometimes it's the right thing to do, but isn't the right
thing to do out of fear probably almost never.
Let's talk about it, you've got time, let's discuss this, let's walk through it so you
really feel peace about your decision or you know that God is leading you and then you could
really have confidence that it's going to work for you.
And if you do decide to do chemo, then let's be wise about it.
This is just a picture clip from our blog post that I did on a protocol to support those
doing chemo. So if you're going to do chemo, then you need to again schedule a time to talk
to myself or Michelle or Anna Ashley here to go through to get our protocol on chemotherapy and
to formulate it, what's going to be perfect for you to help pull us out of your body after it
does its work on the cancer and give it its best chance to work on the cancer utilizing some dietary
approaches and fasting and the right machine and then when it's time to pull it out of the
body after about 48 hours, we'll help pull it out of the body and do less damage to your healthy
cells because that's the whole idea. If we're going to do chemo, we want it to kill the cancer,
so we want it to give it the best advantage to kill the cancer and then secondly we want it to
not kill your healthy cells. So we want to detox that chemo and support those detox pathways.
So let us let's be wise about it. If we're going to do it, let's do it wisely and get it out of your
body. And then lastly about this wisely thing, all of our patients, we're in this stage of
reasoning together about what we're going to do with this. One of the wise decisions we often make is
we don't necessarily follow the schedule, but they're laying out for you. If they're saying we need
10 rounds of chemo every two weeks, it doesn't mean you do. So how did they come up with that?
Did they just throw a dart at the wall? Well no, it's been through science and
not really. If you really dig down, they didn't necessarily do a study whether people need
5 rounds of chemo or 10 rounds of chemo. And it's certainly if they did any study like that,
it wasn't based upon weight, it wasn't based upon body type, it wasn't based upon age,
it wasn't based upon the specific cancer, it certainly wasn't based upon you. So
what you need is not it's not usually what the standard protocol is, what's written in their
merc manual, what from some pharmaceutical company came up with, or a board from the pharmaceutical
company came up with what is the normal protocol for your type of cancer. So we've had many patients
do chemo therapy, maybe just one round to knock the tumor down, maybe do two rounds, maybe instead
of every two weeks, they didn't want some month, they chose the protocol for themselves. And yes,
there there's oncologists that will work with you just like that. So don't don't think that if
you're going to choose to do some standard oncological approach, be it chemotherapy, radiation
or surgery that you have to buy the whole package from them. So we can pick and choose what we want
to do what's going to be for you. So then lastly we want to just make sure that we are being still
and trusting God in all of this. So really this is one of my life versus here because I'm not very
good at this usually just being still and just trusting God because I want to take charge and
take the bones by the horn and I want to figure this out and I want to solve the problem and that's
that's part of you know the benefit of my personality and the struggle with my personality.
So it's got a kind of double-edged sword and it's hard for me just to stop, be quiet and trust him
and allow his circumstances to work out and his peace to come in my heart before I charge off
and do so stupid. So you might be that same way make sure you just slow down and let God tell you
what to do and and stay the status quo until he does tell you what to do.
Okay I'm going to unmute everybody and we'll open it up for questions if you have questions
if this boy shiny man. Dr. Connor yes I don't have a question I just want to tell you thank you
we made it home safely last night oh fantastic we both slept through the night oh good um
woke up this morning with energy I don't think Randy's been in the house more than 10 minutes
of course um so anyway I I just thank you from the bottom of our hearts and I do want to come visit
your father so please please do yeah so thank you for being here you're always just a treasure
of this stuff a blessing to us you know as so many of our patients are and it's just um
it just I have the best job in the world just because I have
I get to deal with people like you so it's just a blessing well God led us to you so there's no
doubt about it so thank you thank you it goes both ways thank you any other questions
and just a reminder if you guys do have questions you can email them to info at Connor's clinic or
Connor's clinic at Gmail and just please put in the subject line zoom question so I can search for
find it um and uh we'll get those questions answered on the next zoom call
and continue to use Facebook so ask those questions on Facebook too all right thank you guys
have a good night